father dad okay open casket in the room
she goes into the room she's alone with
him sitting as close as I am to you
right now she then tells me and she
otherwise of complete rational mind
she's a real estate agent she's majored
in accounting so her brain has done all
right all right she tells me she had a
conversation with him while he was in
the cask and I said were you were the
words coming out of nothing no he sat up
and spoke to her mm-hmm and I said so
I'm now curious I said what did he said
what'd you talk about why I asked how
are you are you fine and he said don't
worry I'm fine I'm in a better place and
that was kind of the extent of the
conversation and I said I grabbed her
and I said what you know if you're
talking to a dead person ask some real
guests some good questions like where
are you are you wearing clothes are you
is it hot
is it cold who else is there you what
are the sites like are there cloud get
some information but and so I don't see
anybody doing it so I would try to put a
suggestions out there it would be if you
have an encounter with a ghost get some
real data please well Henry Durant
Watson in an ancient text called the
ninth plane directly a you know
approaches that and and through mediums
he asked those questions where are you
do you see us can you come back to us
and so he's inquiring there I'm I I'm
not sure whether the body set up or not
I'm more interested in experiences where
there are these ethereal sort of
residual apparitions that kind of repeat
on a loop where you just you can come on
a Wednesday afternoon at 3:00 p.m. and
see the same spirit again and again as
I've heard from some real-estate
contacts with properties in LA for
instance properties they probably can't
sell in fact you know that that when we
sold our house in Los Angeles there was
a disclosure form that said we had to
disclose any unusual activity in the
house
have to actually say that when we early
on when we moved in there was activity
that could not be explained rationally
or physically it is no way yeah